hi everyone thanks for still staying and
I hope you have at least some energy to
listen to the last talk and in this
presentation I hope to give you some
overview of the things that we're doing
in booking and to share my experience in
implementing machine learning models in
production and I will be happy to share
with you the experience that we get and
the challenges that we've found and also
to provide you some solutions so
hopefully if you face the same
challenges you will have a few ideas of
how to work with them so for those of
you who don't know what booking.com is
booking.com is the biggest charol
company in the world and as a part of
the price own group we are seventh
biggest e-commerce company and we have a
headquarter in Amsterdam but we recently
opened an office in Tel Aviv so in case
you're interested in IT opportunities
here we are hiring a lot of people now
especially the data scientists backand
and any other IT positions and
booking.com is operating in 220
different countries we provide the
support in 43 languages we have 15,000
plus employees and we have a very big
data science community inside of the
company we have more than 100 data
scientists I think it will be close to
180 something like that we have data
science applied in all possible areas in
booking like in marketing and in
recommendation systems in customer
service wherever you think of we have
data science applied there and we have
all different roles and we participate
in different conferences and meetups
that's about booking and the first thing
that you can think of okay you have 180
data scientists enormous amount of data
what kind of challenges you can face
just run the logistic regression in your
problems are solved actually the first
and the biggest problem that we have is
the fact that we have a continuous code
start problem what do I mean by that so
many so shooters who have used Amazon
they know that you come to the trap site
once every few days or maybe a few weeks
but for booking become those people who
come to make a booking you usually don't
most of the people usually don't travel
like every week or every month sometimes
you try once per year twice per year and
it can be very different trips once you
go with your friends the other time you
go for a business trip and then yeah
most of the time that you come to our
website you forget to again and you fear
out that you should do it only at the
end of the process only to get an extra
discount that makes a lot of challenges
because standard applications of machine
learning that you can sync off of like
maybe a good recommendation system based
on your previous history might not be
that applicable ok what's then why do we
have hundred eighty data scientists why
do we need these people actually because
there are a lot of other areas where you
can use machine learning although you
might not have a lot of information
about the user so first of them is for
example contact content summarization so
you come to booking that comb you click
ok nice hotel then 300 reviews should I
read all them no instead of that we use
nice and open techniques and we
summarize everything 300 users said that
it was a wonderful hotel others said
that the breakfast was with another
application is it
we provide content evaluation for you
you come to Tel Aviv you look at 300
different hotels which one is actually a
good one the price that they pay versus
what I will get and we already have an
answer for you we have a page that says
to good value for money so no need to
search for it yourself what we can also
do we can try to segment our users for
example we can predict whether the user
Google flexible in dates and then if we
know that we can say okay maybe you can
go one week later and then you can get
the 50% cheaper options so actually a
lot of cool things where you can apply
machine learning without even knowing a
lot about user however as soon as you
start clicking more informati buttons on
our website we actually know more about
you and your coming warmer so we can
make better predictions and we can serve
your more relevant information so sounds
great
now we know where to apply it what's the
problem
ah even if you have an Amazon to data
and good ideas it's too quite
challenging so the first problem is a
data although you can have a lot the
data that you have might not be the one
that you need so let's imagine you have
a very simple problem your product owner
comes to you and says predict whether
the user wants to have a breakfast or
not and then if yes we will display this
information everywhere breakfast for
free best breakfast in tel-aviv like
users rate this breakfast as a best
thing in Israel well okay I have the
date I'll just say zero when user booked
something with a breakfast no otherwise
okay and I'll have my model actually
what we are trying to target from all
our users we want to take the ones who
wants to book a property with a
breakfast but what we observe in our
data are those users who made a booking
and an intersection of them is those
users who booked it with a breakfast
well that the users whom we want to help
are the ones that didn't make a booking
because for them they actually wanted to
say that oh hey there are options for
that and we don't have the data for that
what we can say is ok we can train our
model only on those users who made it
working and say those who made it
working with the breakfast this is a
positive example in since we didn't make
it who made a book and without a
breakfast these are negative examples
but then we make a very strong
assumption that those users who made a
booking and those who didn't make a
booking at the same users and the the
distribution over the data is exactly
the same which might not be the case so
this is a case of when we have a lot of
unlabeled data where we don't know
whether users wanted something or not
and the small portion of them which
where we actually have the data so in
that kind of problems you can call them
semi-supervised learning problems and
then there are different approaches
depending on the types of missing data
that you have that you can apply there
so you can either try to identify from
those unlabeled data which examples are
negative or you can try to say that
everything that is unlabeled is a
negative example and then you put a
weight on top of it
or you can try to distinguish the label
from the unlabeled data which are
positives and negatives and also apply
some fancy algorithms and actually there
is a very nice paper about it how to do
that from nips and also if you read it
immediately Python code how to apply it
in real data okay we try to do something
with explicit signal but what if we
don't want to use this but maybe we have
some other data about the users that can
tell us what user actually wanted and
one simple solution can be okay
let's not look at about at the users who
made it working but let's look at the
thing that user were doing while
searching maybe those users who clicked
for a filter I want to breakfast these
are the users who wanted a breakfast
okay that's a perfect solution we don't
need to reduce a sample of our users the
problem there can be that although at
some point in your user search journey
you say that you want something for
example I definitely want to spy what
you end up booking is something
different and that was actually not a
critical criteria for you to have spa
sauna
I don't know and a three-star Michelin
restaurant in a place you can also be
without it and then by displaying that
kind of information wouldn't help the
user to find the best property for him
or her so this is another thing that it
is a bit hard to understand what kind of
information from the user interaction is
er actually leads to a decision and in
that case you might maybe think of maybe
we can consider only those users who did
not unclick this filter as those users
for whom it was actually important or
not but maybe you have some other ideas
about it another problem is that as a
user when you come to a website you have
long journey and we try to collect the
information about you during this
journey so I tried to search in a place
in Amsterdam
I start exploring I say okay I'm to
guess one night I'm stirred oh whatever
and by the way I actually have it one
child and I want to stay for two nights
oh my god the prices are so expensive
Amsterdam no I'm going to Harlem it's
like 50 euros cheaper and the
make my booking so at the end what you
have the information that they have
about users is like we have features
about number of guests number of night
place the user wants to go but these are
different things and when you want to
build your model you need to make a
decision whether you take all this
information do you want to take on you
maybe they think that user insert it at
the beginning or maybe at the end
because then the user actually knew what
he wants to take a mold take it in a
logarithm or out of it so unfortunately
there is no right or wrong solution for
that because it will also depend on how
you implement your model so you want to
say that for every user is it joins a
website I want to make a prediction
immediately and they'll never change it
and maybe this is the best choice
because you want to optimize based on
that or maybe when you say that okay as
soon as user gets some make some
interactions I want to update my
prediction and then will make will
change the classification value every
time so that I will show relevant
information differently and then you
actually need to do then for every you
want to do it for a mode so that every
most of the time I will show the right
prediction so that's again a decision
okay
the other problem modeling let's imagine
that you have a very simple thing you
want to predict which are the most
relevant Hotel hotels for the user okay
I have the the history of the hotel that
user have seen and then I decide okay I
just make a binary classification hmm
and say everything that user booked is a
positive example and the rest what he
didn't book as a negative example and
that also might sound like a very simple
problem however there is a very strong
bias that you might not directly think
of so the probability that the user will
book the first hotel on the top it's
actually higher than the hotel that we
pay show on page number 33 just because
the user doesn't have time to scroll
through all possible pages and all
possible results and the deeper and the
lower on the page the hotel is the lower
is approved
that the user will click on this
although the relevance of this hotel on
the bottom might be extremely high and
way better than the hotel that is on the
top and this is called the position by
it and what we want to do we want to
learn it from the data so that we can
become decomposed two things the
probably to estimate the probability
that user would book it is the
probability that user will find it
relevant but also that the the Prabhu's
that the user will click on it given the
position so there are some standard
solution that literature proposes one of
them is randomization aerial traffic so
you just randomize your search result
this for all the users and then you see
what was actually clicked and then you
learn this bias but can you imagine what
kind of problems can be with this
solution you start showing random
properties for the user and then you
might show something extremely relevant
and then users just get pissed off and
then they say ok where I'm not going to
use this website and then this is a
problem for the company but a very nice
paper have recently been published it
was published only two weeks ago and
there they were showing that although
the best option is to do this by
randomized controlled mutations but you
can also try to approximate this
position bias even from the
observational data although it wouldn't
be necessarily the exact thing but you
can save some money and not make that
your users disappointed so a very nice
paper how to learn these position bias
from the data and some Python code how
to learn that kind of things problems
that are called learning trunk in Python
if you want they don't want to randomize
it completely because
courage the user instead you're using
some other technique but like didn't
quite understand how this what this
technique does to that user take that at
the data set of the sales no it's it
considered so all the different users
searches behavior and then the clicks
that user made and then so I don't go
into the details because it's quite
complex but you also compare the
relevance of the of the clicks for
example one interesting thing is that
the fact that user haven't clicked on a
have clicked on position number two but
haven't clicked on position number one
kind of may suggest you that position
number one was not that good but it
doesn't tell you what whether the
position number 300 wasn't good enough
for the user so this is one thing there
is a kind of a pairwise matching but
then also based on this pairwise
matching you if you have a lot of data
then you can try to estimate some parts
of this position bias using e/m
algorithm so this is quite complex but
yeah you with a big date you try to
estimate this piece of this position
base so bend it algorithm is also mean
that you randomized some some parts
right so for those people for those
options for whom for which you don't
know you can put it on top and then you
try to learn something which still means
that you might lose some some of your
traffic because this is something that
where you actually not sure and I can
have negative effect on your metrics as
well it's a possibility but it's again
closer to the randomization option which
is a valid solution the other problem is
that sometimes we think that I make a
great model but what we like to say
machine learning is correlation is not
causation so what we predict might not
be that the user intent but what the
user had to do because he didn't find
what he wanted and let me give you the
same example so we want to predict
whether user want to
book a property with a breakfast okay I
made a model a you see a 0.8 I'm super
happy I made a great job but actually
one of my main features is city where
user goes to why would it determine
whether user wants to have a breakfast
another maybe but there is something
there it but then I looked at the data
and when I saw is it for example in st.
Petersburg out of two thousand
properties seventy five of them do not
have an option breakfast ever because
just these are just apartments and in
Palma de Majorca seventy percent of them
have breakfast included by default so
whether you want it or not it will be
just there and then this is an example
when maybe we are not modeling the user
behavior but just the fact that if you
want to book something in some pitches
work with a breakfast while you're
scrolling for two thousand properties
you haven't found the right option and
in that case is the first thing that is
good to do is try to analyze what what
your coefficients in the model means and
the other thing maybe you can think of a
different set up so that if a comparison
would be fair maybe you can think of the
you may be narrowing down your sample to
only the users who saw both options for
one hotel like where it hotel or
property had post having breakfast not
having breakfast but then trying to
extrapolate it based on some kind of
weight there can be options so the main
problem is that we try to actually
predict what user wanted hunt what user
had to do and then the solution here is
to analyze the data and try to again
dive deeper into the biases that can be
there
I eventually even you have thought about
all possible biases in your data still
the last thing that you need to do is to
do to try everything in the experiment
and that's what we do a lot in
booking.com so every model that we want
to introduce we test it in a be testing
so we split our users let's say this
will be group a this will be group B
this will be will have our previous
model that group will have our new model
and then we try to see whether there is
a significant difference in
user behavior between these two groups
and then we we have really a lot of
experiments that we run all the time but
then it tries to help you if you see
that there is no difference in user
behavior maybe you haven't thought about
but specific biases and then they're
still there so you are not predicting
what you want or maybe that you are they
your hypothesis that user might ever
want to breakfast it just not a very
good one so the summary is that there
are a lot of biases you know data there
are no golden rules how you can extract
all of them but just by knowing some of
them cannot actually help a lot and they
try to analyze your model not just say
my model performs well and even if the
model performs great you should still
test it in an experiment and try to
start with simple experiments simple
models test it and then learn what what
was the constraint that you didn't take
into account and thank you very much and
maybe you have some more questions here
so because we are working with 220
countries usually we make the model for
all the countries at the same time where
the country is the future but in
depending on the topic if we think that
this is very specific to this country
maybe you might think of that you need
to do a very specific model but usually
we try to scale it and so that model
will be just a country will be just a
feature any more questions
what do you mean by how do we manage the
features so your question is like how do
we collect the features or the
information about the user
as soon as customer and joins our
website that's a start and then we start
to show we run very many models and then
every model has different features that
it uses and then we have different
models in different places so user sees
these models and then if user behavior
changes the outcome of the models can
also potentially change maybe some
sometimes not but it depends on what is
the setup of the model as well you can
also change the outcome of the model
dynamically when the user behavior
change okay thank you very much
[Applause]